in the center of wrecker is the main
football stadium
they're holding victory celebrations
here at the moment but through Islamic
states reign of terror it was synonymous
with death people brought here rarely
left a group of soldiers told me to
follow them into the bowels of the
building to understand the sheer horror
of this place this is Islamic state
prison of death the soldiers told me the
vast complex was split into women and
men's sections but as we moved on they
explained how it was also used to move
people secretly this is one of the
Islamic state tunnels that we've seen so
often before was interesting the
soldiers here are saying that there are
markings deep down actually giving
directions because these go to different
hospitals in different parts of the city
but these are sort of between two and
you know three or four kilometers away
some massive tunnel system it's how
they've been able to survive the aerial
bombardment you look up here it's
exactly why those tunnels were here in
the first place we've seen it in every
town we've been to in the fight again
examine it state it was a system that
worked for them which means they could
hold on for so long
prison cells branch off a long Central
Corridor inside they showed me where the
condemned wrote the final messages
people who were writing on these walls
knew that they were going to die and the
prisoners writing so they would these
are set what are these messages almost
to their families discovered just days
ago the prison feels dreadfully unsafe
and intense they told me to keep to hard
surfaces the cells on either sides very
some are large some breeze block
chambers a few meters square
this really is horrendous place hundreds
thousands of people perished here the
only ones who survived appear to be
those that were rescued by the soldiers
these cells were bringing people to die
goodness knows some of them will have
done virtually nothing of any
consequence this is really a dreadful
dreadful place almost anyone could end
up here
anyone who fell out with the terror
organization we've always known that if
Islamic state fighters wanted to desert
or at least there was a suspicion they
would they would be arrested and put in
cells like this one and we can see from
some of them names around of the
Chechens Albanians written on the wall
we found abu saeed al Bertani a
well-known british jihadis who's
disappeared we don't know what happened
to him but it appears that this is where
he probably ended his days it's his name
this is the date 24 the second 2016 and
these they believe of the days that he
spent in prison that sort of traditional
thing that prisoners do we wondered what
had happened to him perhaps ultimately
he faced his fate was decided here as
the prisoners were interrogated and
processed they moved along the corridor
the real horror about to begin in this
chamber metal beds this is where they
were strapped down and electrocuted
worse was yet to come
we've told that men were put chained
- these machines they're basically gym
equipment machines and then there would
pulled up and over the back of them so
that they were in absolute agony
disorientated in a huge amount of pain
they then came into this dreadful room I
haven't seen this myself I've seen it in
the death camps of the Nazis but people
would be strung up along here you could
see the chains and was still here they
would then be beaten still further they
were dragged out to the corridor and
taken towards the light at the top of
the steps they were executed Durham G
Sky News in wrackers prison of death